الى باكستان التي تشهد يوما داميا وافادت
السلطات والباكستانيه بمقتل 36 شخصا وجرحي
العشرات معظمهم من رجال الشرطه في انفجار
داخل مسجد بمدينه بيشاور شمال غربي البلاد
ونقل مراسل الجزيره عن مسؤول الامنيا قوله
ان المسجد يقع بالقرب من مقر شرطه المحليه
وبدوره افاد مسؤول في شرطه الباكستانيه عن
رفع مستوى التاهب الامني في العاصمه
اسلاميه بعد انفجاري كما نقلت رويترز عن
رئيس الوزراء الباكستاني قوله انفجار
المسجد في بشاور نجم عن هجوم الانتحاري
امانه من اقليم السند الجنوبيه باكستان
مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد الرحمن مطر طبعا
هجمات المساجد
في افغانستان كثيره وايضا في باكستان لكن
ما الجديد في هذا الهجوم ما الذي يختلف
فيه عن هجمات سابقا
طبعا هذا الهجوم يؤكد بان حركه طالبان
باكستان التي تبنت المسؤوليه مصره على
استهداف الشرطه الاسيمه وانها تفعل ذلك
منذ نحو ااه ثمانيه اسابيع الان استهداف
مباشر للشرطه تحديدا في اقليم خيبر
وعاصمته مدينه بيشاور وايضا في المناطق
المحاذيه لافغانستان وهو بالتاكيد همم ما
يشير الى ان الحركه مصره على استهداف همم
الشرطه تحديدا في هذه المناطق هجوم اليوم
حتى الان اسفر عن سقوط نحو 36 قتيلا وعدد
كبير من الجرحى عندما تمكن انتحاري من
الدخول الى المسجد اثناء اداء المصلين
لصلاه الظهر بشكل جماعي وقام بتفجير كميه
من المتفجرات كانت بحوزته بحسب احد
المسؤولين الامنيين في الحكومه المحليه في
اقليم خيبر رئيس الحكومه الباكستانيه شباب
الشريفه الذي انتقل من العاصمه باد الى
بشار للاطلاع الشخصيه على تفاصيل هذا
الحادث وجه دعوه بالمناسبه للتبرع بالدم
لسيما وان هناك حاجه ماسه الان في
مستشفيات الحكوميه التي يعالج فيها هؤلاء
المصابين من هذا الهجوم لعينات من الدم
ليتمكنوا من مساعده هؤلاء وانقاذ ربما
حياه بعض منهم تحديدا منهم في حاله خطره
الهجوم بالتاكيد كبير همم ربما تكون له
الكثير من التداعيات في المرحله المقبله
لاسيمه انه ياتي بعد فتره هدوء نسبي بين
حركه طالبان باكستان المحظوره هنا في
باكستان والحكومه الباكستانيه او القوات
المسلحه الباكستانيه همم حيث تم التوصل
الى ما يشبه وقت اطلاق النار لكنه انهار
العالم
نعم نعم بالفعل الحركه الطالبان باكستان
اعلنت مسؤوليتها عن هذا الهجوم وقالت انه
ياتي ضمن سلسله استهدافها ل ااا الرموز
الحكوميه بحسب البيان الرسمي الذي اصدرته
الحركه قبل بعض الوقت وهناك بالتاكيد
تحقيقات ما تزال جاريه لمحاوله تعرف اكثر
على التفاصيل همم هناك اجماع على ان
التفجير وقع بناء على ثغره امنيه تمكنت
مكنت هذا المهاجمه من تحاري من الدخول لكن
حقيقه هنا في باكستان المساجد عاده لا
تشهد تفتيش لدى الدخول اليها الا بعض
المساجد يوم الجمعه تحديدا الذي تمكن منهم
المهاجم اليوم هو من الدخول الى المسجد
والذي معظم مصليه من الشرطه يعني انه كان
بالفعل يريد الشرطه وهو بالفعل ما وقع
اليوم
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا عبد الرحمن مطر مدير
مكتب الجزيره في اسلام